with the whole wedding thing kind of
transformed my mentality yeah my husband
now it's so weird I don't know why she
hey guys welcome back to another video
here on our channel we are still in
Dallas and so we decided to do this
little quick 2017 wrap up video and just
talking about how awesome this year has
been so this year has been amazing cuz
we got married so they're very eventful
here because of that what else happened
to one we went to France twice and
that's unheard of for me I don't I don't
hate going back to the same place over
and over again but this time we went to
France twice reason for good reasons
first time was to actually plan the
wedding second time was for the wedding
it's gonna cool that we're sitting on
the same couch where I found out about
the first strip that is right this is
this is pointless
yeah exactly one year ago I gifted TIFF
for Christmas some plane tickets to
France so that we can plan the wedding
yes that's pretty cool coming back a
whole year later and now we're married
and everything happened like all that
same excitement from last year it's like
now it's the aftermath of it and now
it's like cool so this is what it's like
now after this is any different at this
point it feels yeah completely the same
oh one different it feels good we think
that's thank you ever since we've gotten
married and like everyone's been asking
me why God usually Endeavor yeah with
you you know like it's kind of the same
thing I mean if you're living together
it's pretty much the same thing
especially cuz once he live together I
mean that is the married life you're
sharing a the same space you're sharing
responsibilities so it really hasn't
changed at all
yeah my brother I was driving with my
brother the other day and he was asking
me like when do you know that you're
ready to get married and I was like man
I didn't know but the main reason was
the fact that I've already done
everything with you in terms of like how
to progress our relationship I think we
went through a honeymoon phase when you
first started dating then we went
through like our luring a rough patch or
rocky when we arguments or whatever hey
you guys don't know
yeah our relationship is far from
perfect we've worked on this for many
years now and so in the beginning it was
really really tough because we were both
immature we had a lot to learn and grow
and we've ended up helping each other
mature and grow together sometimes I
feel like this is a pretty successful
relationship up until this point right
because now we have to start as manic
cessful anymore no at this point cuz now
this is like the true tableau is for the
rest of our lives you really have to
work on this marriage and constantly
work on it and be happy and try to
always look towards the future that's
true if there is one thing that's
different about being married is that
when we do get to our arguments now
there's more of a need to like need to
fix things and like actually work on our
problems now because this is forever now
you know you can't just let things slide
anymore yeah I think it a path at least
from my perspective in our relationship
and when we argue and stuff like in the
past it was like I'm mad at him whatever
I'm gonna be mad and hold that grudge
but then now I guess the change that now
that we're married it's like okay I'm
mad at him but let me take a step back
look at the big picture it was really
worth being mad at No and then so you're
in there working on it so at least
that's how it's changed for me and my
perspective I said something really
profound the other day I can't forget
what I you just made him cry yeah you're
said something about like how even
though that we're arguing and we're
bickering sometimes even in those
moments you feel like we're still moving
forward in a positive way because what
relationship in this world that matters
to you at all doesn't come with conflict
doesn't come with arguments and I'm like
your best friend you're gonna argue with
the best friend no matter what your
parents or brothers and sisters your
cousins you know like everyone that you
actually care about in this world every
relationship you're gonna argue with
that person no matter what eventually
and so for a husband and wife
boyfriend-girlfriend fiance's that's no
different you know what I said so what I
remember we
had just had like this big ol fight and
it was I think like a full day that we
were not even talking to each other and
in those moments when you're arguing
with the person that you love you feel
like man this relationship like it's not
that we're maybe like we're fighting
like this isn't a good thing this isn't
a good sign but then I started I took a
step back and I was like wait fighting
is good if that's how we learn and
that's how we were able to grow and fix
our problems or like try to work
together to like fix and whatever is
wrong so then I that's when I started
appreciate all those fights and in
specifically that fight because once we
resolve that fight we ended up learning
more about each other and my tweet grew
closer so I was like oh yeah like
fighting is good so yeah and that's
taught me that it running away from your
problems and that working out our our
differences just means that we're weak
about our relationships though yeah but
anyways back to the whole wrap-up of the
year though we're all talking about
relationships what else happened what
was your favorite moment this year well
I mean besides the wedding sighs the way
I came in
okay what's your favorite part of the
wedding the favorite my favorite moment
of the wedding was walking back from
after like saying I do walking back my
that's my - yeah - the Bobby Yom and
they were just like oh this is our
moment just the two of us that was my
favorite and then like when we were
taking photos and then the photographer
was telling us like look into each
other's eyes nothing I was like whoa
yeah and that's what I was like oh my
god he's my husband and then like in
Barcelona - in our honeymoon it's like
no oh you mean this is so cool like just
the entire wedding package it was just
amazing it was just the highlight of my
year I didn't I didn't think that
getting married and like wearing this
ring would affect me too much but it did
oh you started telling me how people
treat you differently yeah like because
I'm wearing a wedding ring like one like
I get carded less now I'm gonna go Tracy
but it's like oh this guy must be at
least you know torn mid 20s or something
you have a wedding ring right and then
like I don't I just people just kind of
approach you look bit differently they
kind of you know give you a little bit
more respect cuz like I look young and I
know that like I'm mom with I'm almost
and like I know I look I could pot I
could pass for high school if I really
wanted to right maybe not but definitely
college college-age for sure and yeah
people like that you know before the
wedding ring it was like oh there's a
kid you know and like what does kid know
about stuff for whatever you know but
now I feel more manly about things you
know and people give you that manly
respect you know so that's pretty cool I
did did anything change for you like
with their what bandar ever since I got
engaged I know I don't get hit on
anymore which is like good thing because
I always get like really awkward in
those moments around like you know it
doesn't stroke her ego as like a
beautiful young woman that that people
hit on you or no I feel weird like I
don't know I don't feel we're now saying
on you when we first met yes especially
because I have just not another
relationship when I was telling you
about that and you're still hitting on
me I'm like man I have no respect for
what I'm saying boys will be boys [ __ ]
no but yeah like I guess that's one of
the main things but I mean it's already
been closer to like almost two years a
year and a half that I've had a ring on
my lip yeah yeah so it's been a while
that like I just got used to being
treated differently because people do
notice when there's a ring on your hand
yeah does it make you feel like this is
something different to wear I noticed
was I gradually actually from the moment
got engaged I naturally started feeling
I knew I needed to change my wardrobe
and change the way I walked well I'm not
change in a way of I'm changing my
identity but just there's certain
aesthetics about my life that I hadn't
actually kind of wanted to change and it
wasn't like I kept telling that Casey
the shiny marijuana better I mean this
should I can hear when I only dealt with
for maybe like a month and then okay no
chocolate yeah but they had to deal with
the the t-shirt and chucks we're like
okay Wayne the same clothes every day
I'm like and then every especially when
we go out to like a friend's dinner
like come on I'm looking nice can't you
like at least try to at least match me a
little bit like come on so tonight let's
light now I'm glad that you're getting
more into looking good especially like
you know you're wearing more watches and
especially with that rings thank you do
you feel any different like do you feel
like like being a wife really changed
like some sort of like well I do kind of
feel a little like whoa that's weird or
that's new or different whenever I refer
to you as my husband I feel like we have
my husband or like whenever I'm making
an appointment for something I'll be
like yeah my husband and whatever so
it's just like wow that's different
layers yeah I'm like now like I realize
like I'm a mom and a wife it's funny
because you're at home I think almost 10
right so I should have about a good
decade of being used to being called the
mom but till this day I still can't wrap
my head around the fact that I'm a mom
for some reason I don't know maybe you
moms out there can relate to me like
it's just so weird like I think about it
and I see him and I'm like I gave birth
to you I had you in my stomach and like
it's just so weird it's just been 10
years and I still can't get used to the
fact that I'm a mom and so now I'm
actually a white people it's it's weird
those titles are they it's like they
don't mean much if you think about it
but then at the same time they mean a
lot
yeah it's like to me like something big
that happened this year was Isaac
started calling me daddy and I I don't
know like once he like told me that like
he was ready to like go into that realm
of our relationship all of a sudden I
became like dude you're my best friend
man like you're a broad I mean kind of
relationship to oh I need to set a
better example like you know like I
can't be asked he's like not that I was
crazy to begin with but like you know
there's certain things that I do feel
like you know past five years you know
it was definitely like a younger 20s
kind of vibe and now even though I'm
still not 30 yet but like I feel like
okay I need a start kind of
fast-forwarding my progression in terms
of maturity to set a better example so
that you know it's a little more stable
you know for him to have someone to look
up to and I remember when he was telling
me like
so do you think it'd be weird if I call
KC daddy and I was like no I mean you
can call him whatever you want I mean KC
has always said like you know he could
call me your best friend you could call
him KC just anything you want like
there's no pressure
like just whatever you feel comfortable
he's like yeah but it's kind of weird I
feel weird and I was like well again in
the beginning it's gonna be worse is
this transition phase and you kind of
gotta get over but you'll get over it
and they'll it'll feel like it's natural
but it's up to you and I just kept like
I've made it crystal clear and there's
no pressure it's up to you it got to a
point where he started thinking about it
he started thinking about his own daddy
he's like well do you think my dad will
get upset if I call KC daddy and I was
like well why don't you ask him like you
can talk to him about it and and just
find out how he feels about it and so
then that's when his dad came over to
pick him up and then we all had a
conversation cuz I brought it up was
like yeah so I didn't kind of wanted to
ask you if it's okay with you to call KC
daddy and that's when his dad was like
of course like he is like his dad like
him it's so beautiful that his dad
recognizes how great of a dad KC is and
like how much effort KC puts into
Isaac's life like that just touches my
heart and I love the fact that we're all
on the same page and I could see it in
Isaac's eyes too because he's so burly
like he doesn't have like this like
weight on his shoulders of like oh man
it has like two dads and like exercise
we can talk about this dad with this dad
so it's just really nice to see that he
doesn't have that pressure and just he's
able to be free and just have all the
parents in his life and we all work
together and making like a parent team
for him and so it was just really
beautiful I love seeing especially when
he started calling you dad or daddy you
that's when I was like oh that's so
sweet like now Isaac has someone in his
own home that he can refer to as mommy
and daddy in the same household and that
just like it touches me a lot because I
remember growing up and I wish I had the
same I'm gonna cry
good but yeah like it just growing up I
always wish I could have that in my own
home my son have it it just means a lot
to me so thank you for being missing
yeah thank you for having me yeah I'm
trying hard not to cry but yeah it's
just I don't know cuz I remember like I
had a stepdad but we didn't get along
and I wouldn't just call him by his
first name and stuff and I just always
wish like I had a dad at home so ya know
but yeah yeah we're becoming like
full-blown parents at this point and
then what's crazier is all our friends
yeah when we met in the early 20s so
like we look at we look at each other
like we're still in our early 20s I mean
I give for some reason you don't ever
lose sight of that first impression when
you first meet them you see them as that
age like yeah like Joe Willow forever be
that the bald like crazy guy the cholo
guy Bart's forever gonna be the marine
like crazy dude that drives the truck up
over curves and and no I know that guy
there's no first impressions that ya
that I got on to for some reason but now
I you know we've known each other for 10
years now or Hooper friends and like
yeah and so many of our friends had kids
this year yeah it's like that's great
wow that's so cool seeing tyka like yeah
so 2017 has been an amazing year for us
wedding and babies and and just becoming
adults yeah and we want to leave you
with this nice little montage shoutouts
to Nigel for editing the video clip hit
me up on Twitter with something he had
edited before it as a tribute to our
channel and I loved it so much I thought
I was watching my own editing yeah he
like replicated my style is crazy so we
had him help me out with editing this
montage Shasta Nigel check out his
YouTube channel in the description below
and enjoy enjoy happy new year
2018 here we come
[Music]
[Applause]
you wanna tell them why we're going to
Paris these two are going to get married
in the Paris our wedding is finally
coming to fruition
today's objective is picking a venue
there was three concept love that my mom
told me that I'll get to understand when
I'm older the first one was the love
that you have as a child to your parents
the second is going to be when you meet
your significant other third is gonna be
when you have it when you have Isaac
Ganesha know what that feels like as
well they're gonna be cake tasting with
Baker
do the dark times and the low times I
promise to you that I will make it
things brighter and higher for you you
have helped me grow until the person I
am today and I owe forever be grateful
for that and I just promised to be the
best wife I can be your best friend
forever and always be your number one
fan no matter what I now pronounce you
Casey and Tiffany Chad you may now kiss
the brother
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
today I feel that same sort of excited
feeling you get when you sleep over your
best friend's house
you're just having the greatest time of
your lives and you never want it to end
I feel like that today but times a
million because I know that this is
never gonna end I get to have that
special sleepover with my best friend
for the rest of my life and I'm so happy
pretty hot away but this is not what you
showed Russian eating like they don't
taste like
[Music]
[Music]
we made my whole room into this little
Clubhouse so I'm gonna be giving you
guys a tour
[Applause]
[Music]
I think was next to me when I was
starting to learn it the first one that
he got was
[Music]
I take a little very seriously
look who came to visit us in the
clubhouse
[Music]
Oh
today TIFF and I are leaving for
Catalina Island and not only are we
going as a romantic getaway but it's
also a birthday getaway for tip I fear
good makes you look more puffs I like it
mannequins return the reverse Michael
Jackson
[Music]
do you remember when you were little
like you know you saw me holding a
camera and shooting you know movie
everywhere we go
yeah do you think it was kind of
embarrassing that if we were doing that
no no cool now you're doing it
[Music]